well good evening welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored Donald Trump is right
back where he likes to be he's leading
cable news he's generating headlines
across the planet and he's smacked bang
in the middle of the storm of his own
making and one that's of course all
about him viewers tuning into CNN's
Infamous already Infamous Town Hall last
night could have been forgiven for
thinking it was a rerun from 2016. this
was Trump the showman shooting from the
hip with insults falsehoods and
outrageous diversions at a friendly
audience full of Republicans that like
him met with laughter and Applause
however inappropriate that may have been
firmly in his crosshairs was e Gene
Carroll a woman that a civil jury had
just decided this week had been sexually
abused by Trump in the 1980s and been
defamed by him as a liar
I never met her I have no idea who she
is I had a picture taken years ago with
her and her husband nice guy John
Johnson he was a newscaster a very nice
man she called him an ape happens to be
African African-American called him an
ape the judge wouldn't allow us to put
that in
her dog
or her cat was named vagina
well it was textbook Trump wasn't it for
every criticism there was a baseless
insult aimed at somebody else grilled on
holding classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago responded simply by attacking
the hosts from CNN Caitlin Collins
why you held on to those documents when
you knew the federal government was
seeking them and then had given you a
subpoena to return are you ready are you
ready can I talk yeah what's my answer
can I do you mind I would like for you
to answer the question okay it's a very
simple day that's why I asked it it's
very simple that you're a nasty person
I'll tell you what
this is how Trump dominated the election
cycle of course when he propelled
himself to that stunning victory in the
first place in 2016. Rosie O'Donnell was
a fat pig he said Hillary Clinton was
crooked and so on and so on everyone was
a loser apart from him Isis will lose it
CNN was sick losers with very bad
ratings billionaire Mike Bloomberg was a
loser as money but can't debate Hillary
Clinton was the worst ambiguous loser of
all time every time Trump spoke or
tweeted you reshape and use agenda
around himself let's be honest all the
time it was entertaining and sometimes
laugh out loud funny but lots changed
since 2016. it doesn't feel entertaining
or funny anymore there's a lot of murky
water now under the Trump Bridge he
helped Insider riots at the Capitol but
people died last night I said he might
pardon some of the rioters he's been
criminally indicted over hush money to
the porn star Stormy Daniels he's been
proven in a civil court of sexually
abused a magazine writer he could yet
face charges for trying to find votes to
overturn defeat an election which he
still claims is rigged and that's why
this all feels very different than
2015-16
yes Trump is the front runner to be the
Republican nominee yes 74 million people
did vote for him in 2020 yes he could
well be the next president of the United
States again there's also misinformation
machine spewing fake news across the
planet faster than anyone can keep up
with it and if America is going to get
to grits for the second coming of Donald
Trump it's going to have to figure out
how to handle his incessant lies